did you ever feel like you were loved as
a child no no and because I'd never had
been I didn't really miss it either no I
believe to this day I probably still
don't know what my place
all right BJ yes BJ were you from
originally
where'd you grow up I grew up in how I
wouldn't have anything San Francisco for
like 30 years
tell me about your childhood yet both
your parents growing up as a child I had
no family growing up where were your
folks
I don't know again I still dumb the home
so you never knew your parents know who
raised you I broke pretty much in
juvenile hall I'd go in a foster homes
but something bad always happening I
always ended up back in juvenile hall so
do you even know how became home to me
after why I got to where that's where I
wanted to be you know in advance we'll
go to juvenile hall and run away to get
out I used to run run away from hostile
homes to go back to you in my Hawk it
was why I knew where I was comfortable
oh well what kind of childhood do you
have how would you describe it alone
very unstable I was never in any one
place for more than two or three months
did you have any traumatic events as a
kid or any abuse thing like that yeah I
I got thrown through a wall one time for
wetting the bed I was home from the
bedroom all the way through the wall
into the living room because I wet the
bed I was like eight years old I went to
bed and the foster family didn't like
that too much
and I had one faster friend me that the
only reason they even had any foster
kids was that they had somebody to beat
on and they used to be this mercilessly
for no reason pretty much every day and
most of the fossil hunt I ended up in
they only had a spare so they could get
paid because they get paid a certain
amount of money for each kid they have
and some of the foster homes sadly eight
ten twelve kids there that they didn't
care about it was just about the money
so I mean I
had a good childhood in the sense that I
didn't have any anybody telling me if
you don't finish your journey you got to
go to bed but at the same time I didn't
have anybody telling me here's your
dinner enjoy it yeah I never know if I
was gonna have something to eat or not
did you ever feel like you were loved as
a child no no and because I'd never had
been I didn't really miss it either no I
believe to this day I probably still
don't know what my place I believe I'm
starting to love myself I haven't been
locked up in over 20 years this is the
best I've ever had in my life together
yeah I've got a permanent place to live
I pay rent
I've got TV I've got a nice nice room
like that everything in my room was
bought and paid for I've got a nicer or
nice entertainments there pretty cat
food love me this is the best point in
your life so far yeah how old are you 60
to 62 yeah and what was the worst plane
your life
LA County Jail where were you in jail
for on this forging prescriptions
doctor's prescriptions for different
drugs in Hollywood and for a white boy
who go into LA County Jail with
swastikas all over him oh it was ugly
every time my door got opened for dinner
or shower or anything at least three
black guys would brush in my cell and
beat the dog [ __ ] on me every time my
slogan opened that happen and it was
nothing I could do about I was the only
white boy on the whole tier that was the
ugliest time of my life that can
remember tell me about the swastika
tattoos on your chest in our um I went
to prison while I went to trace you - 17
at that time Tracy was called the
gladiator school it was where the really
rough cases started out they would go to
Tracy and learn how to be a convict and
then go from their City to San Quentin
or Folsom and I went in a pretty boy
from Hollywood
seven
years old and I was scared and I didn't
wanna get raped and I didn't wanna have
my [ __ ] taken from me and I was offered
an opportunity to ship up with their and
Brotherhood I told your wife you know be
with us stay with us we'll take her you
teach everything you need to know give
you anything you need to have and I did
and I never got jumped for beat up by
blacks at all but I had to participate
in rats in order to do that I would have
to share weapons and stab people in the
yard and you know any send anything
jumped off between whites and any other
race if I was there and didn't get
involved then they would beat the hell
out of me for it so I mean it had its
pros and cons but I survived I just went
ahead to survive I'm not a racist
I don't have a lot of black friends I am
a little bit prejudiced but the same
thing that I hate black people for if
white people were doing it I hate them
for it too this [ __ ] mentality that's
all I can say is that's what it is and I
don't like it in whites blacks greens
Purple's there anyway I appear to be a
lot more prejudiced that I am because
mostly I've outgrown that but plus I've
gotten to work like I said I'm satisfied
with my life I don't bother anybody I
don't let anybody bother me I do my
thing and go my way
yeah I'm not trying to interrupt you or
bother you and I'm not gonna let you do
that to me
how many years have you lived in the
Tenderloin in San Francisco I've been
though for 30 or 35 years there about
and you've been homeless for how long
until like 22 years ago I was always
home and out you're staying in one of
the I'm an SRO SRO the mission hotel and
it's in the Mission District actually
can you come down here for I came down
here to get my check I had my pays off
this is right where we're standing and
that's where I pick up my check that's
where I found you
yeah use any of the drugs that are on
the street I use Helen how long have you
used heroin about ten years yeah and I
don't get high I just maintain I shoot
three times a day just to be functional
I get sick if I don't good and how do
you support yourself prove miss SSI Plus
unnourished I draw a lot of pursue so a
lot of people and different things for
prison itself you know those people they
just plain spirit and they look at me
and hey will you escort me maybe go
shopping or less care for me to pick up
my sack or whether I used to get paid
$50 for that and that happens two or
three times a week did you ever been in
love before I don't think so then you
have no kids
no no I won't have any kids either
I mean what kind of father where I be
yeah no dear friends do I have friends I
have a plane I don't think I have any
better that I would call a friend right
now I'm not that close with anybody and
I don't want to because every time I've
been really hurt really bad it's been by
somebody that was really close to me so
and to say this because I don't feel
like I need anybody for anything I take
care of myself just fine
so I mean all the [ __ ] that comes worth
of friendship I don't need don't want
and yet I'm more than the lack of love
that you had throughout your life how do
you attribute the fact that you're at
your very best point right now on the
hot team giving me house once I got
house my life has been so much better
I'm happy now you know once I get to why
I had a permanent place to live I'm not
just here for a week or a month this is
my home forever when that happened my
whole life changed
yeah they seemed like a great
organization yeah
and makes so much difference have an
address meant and heaven that delivery
that's what it is just the stability and
living up to the responsibility of
heavenly place slip it's kind of nice
yeah and then you can be put in a place
to live and just be so irresponsible
with it you [ __ ] a lot yeah and I don't
do that either
yeah so I do I do appreciate what I've
got and I respect that do you find
having a little responsibility in your
life gives your life meaning yeah yeah
and the lack of responsibility make sure
life meaningless yeah and plus the
feeling of the day it makes me feel like
I've accomplished something it's not
just another wasted day yeah
and that kind of means something because
I don't want to be worthless you know I
don't want to get in the way I don't
want to be in limelight but I don't want
to just exist either yeah I don't know
beechworth I have some value to the
other people other than myself do you
have hope of getting off of heroin one
day um yeah I've been off of it twice
and I started using again not because I
needed the drug because I was born to
death there was nothing else for me to
do I change the bag of their line no
it's what I do if I'm not doing that
there's nothing left it says is to have
to admit there's left not I've checked
twice and went back to using Erebor on
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your your interesting life
just the fact you grow up without love
gives you a very interesting perspective
I would think fresh no one that's real
important cuz I mean we started getting
friendly with Sunday or you get close to
somebody you get to express them more
and more and more and before you know it
you leave them at your house while you
go to the store you know letting them
spend the night because then I have a
place for letting them come over for a
shower and that's when you get ripped
off that's when you get jumped on that's
when you get people talking about you
it's better to just trust no one no keep
your distance talk to me we do it from
over there
all right BJ well thank you for coming
in and sharing your story and I hope
your life continues in a positive
direction he told me what you were doing
and why are we doing it and kudos to you
this needed to be done and you're the
right one to do it - I can tell
thank you very much no problem great
meeting you you too and really thank you
you